just before Thanksgiving we did a week
shows in New York City at the historic
Apollo Theater besides getting to do all
these great live shows being in New York
gave our own Andy Richter a chance to
kick off a new food and travel segment
for the show I am very excited about
this very excited
take it away Andy thanks Conan you know
if there's one food that the Big Apple
made famous
it's the classic slice of New York Pizza
but where can you find the city's best
pizza while I was in New York I made it
my business to find out even if it meant
searching all across all five boroughs
here's my report for Andy Richter's
taste of New York
[Music]
[Applause]
there are over 1,200 pizza restaurants
stretched across New York City's 300
square miles that's a lot of mozzarella
but I'm only interested in the very
upper crust of New York Pizza come on
let's go find the best New York Pizza
[Music]
thanks daddy
oh that's good pizza it's not gonna get
any better than that so there it is
you'll find the best peach in New York
City at the Duane Reade pharmacy on
125th Street in Harlem this is Andy
Richter and that's a taste of New York
wait a minute wait a minute wait a
minute wait a minute what about whoa
what the hell was that in you just went
to a Duane Reade pharmacy half a block
away you can literally see the Apollo
Theater where we were working behind you
it's right there that is the laziest
reporting I've ever seen yeah but I get
paid the same either way that's my taste
of New York
didn't look good yeah
you
you